ich habe bereits drei verschiedenen
merkmalen gemacht ich habe bereits mit
dem puren gemacht ich habe auch bereits
zu den mündern gemacht und heute mache
ich mit den augen erkennst du diese
youtuber an ihren augen
yay
das 3 likes da wirklich einfach mal auf
play sehen schon erkennst du diese
youtube an ihren augen dabei zu den
gleich bilder eingeblendet von youtube
anwender von den augen ihrer youtuber
von den augen ihrer youtuber bin ich
dumm in der tat dass die ersten augen
ich finde das ist relativ simpel lassen
lina sophie würde ich sagen genau da
sehen wir schon melina ein punkt freunde
das ist der erste buch das sind die
zweiten augenbeschwerden überbelichtet
rücklagen andré von hate crime und andré
von help to recover sich auf einmal
klappt an den augen vielleicht nicht so
erkannt aber an den haaren hat relativ
eigenen für ihn sehen wir auch schon
richtig da habe ich überhaupt keine
ahnung ich würde sagen ich
ich wollte gerade katja sagen aber ich
dachte dann die hat nicht so schöne
augen ich muss ganz ehrlich gerade sagen
also wenn wir uns nur die augen
anschauen jetzt nicht dieses komische
geschminkte hier oben aber nur die augen
hier das sind schon extrem schöne augen
und dann können wir uns davon und dann
ist es katja kramer wird lebt der
youtuber haben wir hier würde ich sagen
im korb 21 wenn das jetzt auch aus kommt
ja es ist auch wieder ins lot at was
geht ab ich habe bisher wie viel punkte
habe ich also hier vor dem china hatte
ich richtig dann hatte ich andere
richtig dann hatte ich es richtig kann
ich mich richtig ins qualität vier
punkte von 580 richtig ihr könnt ja
übrigens man einfach wieder mit raten
also einfach die ganzen kommentare
sektion offen haben das kommentar
schreibe fenster und dann immer wenn
augen eingeleitet werden schreibt die
schnell in die kommentare werden wem wir
ob ihr richtig ragt und nicht schießen
ihr kleinen puffer die nächsten augen
sind diese hiermit gläubig zahl
entdeckter der irgendwie so halb
schwarze augen auf diesem bild hier
gerade nächster youtuber in felix von
der laden das relativ erkennbar
eleganten muss einmal die haben staaten
relativ zugekniffenen augen
ja genau lena das heißt ja wird sechs
von liegen sogar recht lackiert paola
diese süßen knuffigen augen ja ich hab's
sieben von acht richtig weiß nicht ob
ihr euch noch an mein letztes video
die youtuber kramt erinnert da hatte ich
einen youtuber von fehler richtig weil
man die an den mündern erkennen mussten
dass war ultra schwierigkeit ich
wirklich nur den allerersten richtig
unterschenkel und hier jetzt gerade habe
ich einfach schon sieben von acht
richtig also wir machen wir weiter
parole hatten wir hier das hier piloten
sieht man einfach an diesen
aufgegriffenen augen und das ist so oben
drüber ging und piloten letzter youtuber
bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher würde ich
sagen julian weiss ich aber jetzt nicht
ganz genau es ist juni
ich habe neun und zehn richtig dass kurz
war schon recht ich schaue mal ein
anderes kürze bezüglich der augen von
youtube anwendern später erkennst du die
youtuber ihren augen ebenfalls von
meetyoo hochgeladen glaube ich hier den
profi edition weil die letzten jahr auch
natürlich relativ privaten kenne ich
schon nicht keine ahnung überhaupt keine
apa red da hätte ich drauf kommen können
hätte ich mich drauf kommen können also
im vorherigen hat die berichte aus china
sowie das sind diese husky augen finde
ich ein bisschen nein oder neun von zehn
ich glaube ich war richtig aber jetzt
richtet man merkt schon dass die
profitieren ist dafür stefan gehrig
dafür könnte ich sogar meine hand ins
feuer erhalten hat auch vermitteln so
ich habe bisher gar nicht richtig auf
und antwortete ich finde das sieht man
doch dass du diese ladung also dass das
hat man auf jeden fall gewinnen das er
tätig war
gerade weil klappen da bin ich mir
überhaupt nicht sicher ich würde sagen
bonität boni tremsbüttel juni bleibt
also weiter der beauty falsch
geschrieben die pelle
hier habe ich überhaupt keinen plan ich
würde sagen andreas ist krank
ich kann gar nichts man das hier jetzt
fiat viel würde ihm sagen also ich hab
einen punkt mehr als st
freiburg das sind leer und man würde ich
jetzt sagen da könnte ich meiner hand
wieder 5 leon masse einem punkte bisher
am start
da würde ich da will ich diesmal sagen
dass es für ihn david
ich habe
hätte gerade also einen punkt habe ich
bisher eher da würde ich jetzt wirklich
sagen dass andere da bin ich mir sehr
sicher bei dieser typische hochgezogene
von den augen ist tadel
das war's
ich hatte einen punkt
beim zweiten clip richtig aber bei dem
ersten kurs nahezu alle der familie
meine damen und herren es euch gefallen
hat das gern mal die vier likes da
schreibt mal youtuber in die kommentare
wenn ich das demnächst nochmal hoch
laden soll weil die videos kommen ja es
war gut bei euch an jetzt würde ich
sagen meine damen und herren rom
er hat die autosparte tier oder haltet
ihr vom video ihr könnt jetzt in einen
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
shop setzt sich jetzt für andere medien
und berlin nach unendlichen die glocke
kriechen dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]